[Musique]
c'est ici que le 17 juin 1972 cinq
personnes inclues avant que son luxe qui
porte le nom de watergate
les cinq individus qui prétendent être
plombier sont en fait ici pour installer
les micros afin d'espionner la direction
du parti démocrate et c'est dans cette
chambre car des proches conseillers de
riscle nixon séjourne afin de pouvoir
surveiller la tentative d'espionnage qui
a lieu juste en face au siège du parti
démocrate on découvre alors que sur les
cinq cambrioleurs quatre ont été actifs
au sein de la cia et le cinquième n'est
autre que le chef de la sécurité du
comité de réélection du président nixon
en 1972 est une année électorale et dans
la culture de la maison blanche de
l'époque la fin justifie les moyens
nexcelle à pousser pousser pousser ses
proches à faire des choses est
clandestine contre les démocrates
l'arrestation de ces cambrioleurs et
bien vite rapporté par deux journalistes
du washington post car holstein et bob
woodward qui vont creuser vraiment très
profondément dans cette sombre histoire
d'espionnage politique aussi
profondément que dans ce stationnement
souterrain de virginie où les deux
journalistes vont recevoir des
informations privilégiées de la part de
10 frotte gorge profonde un informateur
très mystérieux scoop après scoop le
scandale grossit et met en évidence
l'implication de la maison blanche et du
président républicain ce qui n'empêche
pas en novembre 1972 sa réélection
alors affaire classée pas du tout le
problème nixon c'était que la couture
policiers
mais pendant 72 ans 73 face à un
président qui nie tout en bloc ayew
[Musique]
le sénat vote alors à l'unanimité pour
lancer une commission d' enquête
parlementaire il pendant 15 mois va
fasciner mais aussi dégoûté les
américains qui vont suivre les audiences
par dizaines de millions
[Musique]
ils vont apprendre davantage plus sur
les sales coups que fomentait la maison
blanche pipolo garneau
alors que nixon s'empêtre dans le
scandale et consent à faire démissionner
deux de ses proches collaborateurs
tout le monde se pose la question que
savait-il vraiment et depuis qu'en
était-il au courant sur ce point à cause
de sa paranoïa et de sa certaine culture
de l'illégalité le président nixon a
couru à sa propre perte mais c'étaient
les enregistrements qui ont montré
qu'elles nomment excellent excellent a
menti
les demandeurs et l'a fait partie de
tous ses activités sans ces
enregistrements on aura seulement à le
témoignage de deux des gens proches de
lui
[Musique]
sur les neuf enregistrement exigé par le
juge qui veut aller au fond des choses
la maison blanche en fournira sept et
sur l'un d'entre eux il manquera 18
minutes et demie de conversation le juge
de washington ira jusque devant la cour
suprême pour obtenir ces documents
manquants pendant ce temps l'étau se
resserre puisqu'une commission
judiciaire de la chambre des
représentants a compilé 7 milles des
positions afin de préparer la procédure
de destitution du président américain la
maison blanche perd alors sa cause
devant la cour suprême et doit fournir
les retranscriptions des minutes
manquantes des enregistrements qui
décidément incrimine clairement le
président d'exxon quand les républicains
disait au président c'est fini le
président lui même savait que s'il reste
à la maison blanche va perdre à le
procès au sénat a chargé jean et ne pas
gêner ses factures
aideront les bouquets 1974 une première
dans l'histoire américaine nixon
démissionne et quitte la maison blanche
le lendemain
nixon a beau faire le v de la victoire
quand il part c'est d'abord et avant
tout une victoire pour le travail de la
justice et pour le travail des deux
journalistes qui ont mis au grand jour
le scandale qui a sali la réputation de
la maison blanche au fait qu'ils étaient
gorge profonde il faudra attendre 2005
pour découvrir qu'il s'agissait de mark
felt de directeur adjoint du fbi à
l'époque de l'administration nixon il
l'aurait fait pour des raisons éthiques
et personnel
alors que reste-t-il du scandale
aujourd'hui notamment le fameux suffixe
quête du watergate qu'on utilise depuis
pour qualifier les petits et grands
scandales qui entachent la réputation
des politiciens